si estas horas el balance es de más de
700 detenidos en la treintena de
ciudades rusas que celebraron
manifestaciones por segunda vez contra
la movilización parcial decretada por el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin la
preocupación entre los rusos van en
aumento ante una movilización que va a
enviar a cientos de miles de rusos al
frente Durante las próximas semanas
incluso algunos medios rusos siguen
publicando que en realidad la
movilización más va más allá de 300.000
y que llega llegaría en algún momento al
millón de personas a estas horas junto
la preocupación como decía también
Porque algunos medios adelantan que en
cuanto se aprueben los referendos los
resultados de los referéndums que se
están celebrando en Ucrania se va a
denegar la salida del país a todos los
rusos varones en edad de combatir es
algo que no está confirmado pero ya
llegan informaciones desde diversas
regiones fronterizas de que se está
devolviendo a
algunos hombres rusos que intentan salir
y que se les devuelve precisamente se
les rechaza en frontera en base a
peticiones de los centros de
reclutamiento